gençler Merhaba hepiniz hoş geldiniz
kaldığımız yerden devam ediyoruz
besinlerde ydik inorganik bileşikleri
bitirmiştik şimdi organik moleküller ya
da organik besinler şeklinde de
ilerleyebilir bu konuya gireceğiz şimdi
organik dediğimiz zaman genel anlamda
biyolojide karbon hidrojen ve oksijen
üstünlüğü var Neden biyolojide diyorum
Çünkü bir bileşikte karbon olması tek
başına onu organik besin yapmaz
arkadaşlar mesela karbondioksitten
bahsetmiştik o organik değildi ya da Bir
bileşiğin organik olabilmesi için illaki
karbon hidrojen oksijenin üçü de beraber
olmak zorunda değil mesela ileride
organik kimyada ch4 gibi Alkan
göreceksiniz Alkan alken alkin bu tarz
konuları gördüğünüzde bakacaksınız ki
orada oksijen yok ama bir karbon kimyası
var Dolayısıyla ezbercilik yapmıyoruz
buralarda kesinlik sorusu yok Doğada Bir
sürü istisna var geçmişte bunu söylemiş
olmalıyım çok sevdiğim bir hocamın bir
sözü var Her şeyin bir istisnası vardır
istisna Olmayan şey istisnadır diye Eee
bu hakikaten biyolojide böyle Arkadaşlar
şimdi karbohidrat lipit ve protein
özelinde gideceğiz besinlerde bugün
karbohidrat videosu olacak ama sizden
ricam nerede olduğunuzu hangi konuda
olduğunuzu yorumlara Yazın arkadaşlar
ben de ona göre hızımı ayarlayayım Ama
dediğim gibi aşırı derecede yoğun
olduğum için muhtemelen yine bir gece
videosu atacağım Yani gece çekiyorum
zaten genelde videoları ya da Mesaiden
sonra çekiyorum şimdi ne var hocam ilk
konumuz Uz da tabii ki düzenli dengeli
beslenme mantığıyla başlayacağız her
şeyin Fazlası zarar arkadaşlar mesela
Bir besinin çok kaliteli olması sizi
aldatmasın Hocam ben işte her gün
proteinle besleniyorum e ihtiyacından
fazlasını alırsan ne olacak göbek
yapacaksın yani her gün Adana kebap
yiyerek kas yapamazsın fazlası ne
oluyormuş yağ oluyormuş Her şeyin
Fazlası zarar arkadaşlar suyun da mesela
Fazlası zarar birkaç saat içerisinde 6
litre su içerseniz ihtiyacınız yokken bu
sizi komaya sokabilir Hatta öldürebilir
Peki hocam geçiyorum buraları burada
genel bir sınıf çalışmasından
bahsedilmiş ekstra bir şey yok şimdi
çeşitli elementlerin ve fonksiyonel
grupların karbon atomlarına
bağlanmasıyla oluşan moleküller demiş Bu
çok genel bir ifade Tabii ki mesela
burada karbon hidrojen oksijen bunları
verdik ama bazı bileşiklerde bir
bakacağız ekstradan azot var bazı
bileşiklere bakacağız ekstradan fosfor
var bazılarına bakacağız kükürt var gibi
ya da fonksiyonel gruptan kastı Mesela
bir bakacağız yapıya alkol türevi
katılmış mesela gliserol bir alkoldür 3
karbonlu bir alkoldür nötral yağların
yani vücudumuzda Derimizin altında depo
edilen trigliserit nötral yağların bir
gliserol ve 3 yağ asidinden oluştuğunu
göreceğiz ya da karboksil grupları
denilen gruplar olacak bunlara çok fazla
şimdi girmiyorum sadece bunlara bakarak
da bir ön yargınız oluşmasın diye
arkadaşlar hemen şöyle konunun içerine
doğru dalıyorum şimdi Makro molekül
mikro molekül ya da Makro molekül
polimer monomer yapı taşı ifadeleri var
monomer ve polimerlere baktığımızda ki
ÖSYM soruyor arkadaşlar bunları
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi polimer değildir
diye çok da tatlı basit bir soru oluyor
Çat diye yapıştırı musunuz Cevabı şimdi
mesela bakın Yıldız atmışım daha bu sene
sınav
sorusuyla yüzlercesi binlercesi yan yana
gelmesi lazım Mesela ben size diyeceğim
ki proteinler işte yüzlerce binlerce
aminoasitten meydana gelir ya da nişasta
glikojen selüloz kitin gibi birbirine
benzeyen yapıların yüzlercesini
binlercesinin yan yana gelerek
oluşturduğu yapılar polimerdir ama
yağlar lipitler polimer değildir Mesela
nötral yağda 3 yağ asti bir gliserol
dört şey bir polimer değildir büyük
moleküldür dersin ama polimer demezsin
şimdi Dehidrasyon ve hidroliz bakın
kelimeleri kıralım hidro su demek lis
parçalamak demek hidroliz suyla
parçalamak demek Dehidrasyon de atmak
demek hidro su suyun atıldığı
reaksiyonlar Fakat burada hemen Şuraya
bir not almanı istiyorum her su çıkan
tepkime Dehidrasyon
değildir her su harcanan tepkime
hidroliz değildir Mesela hocam örnek ver
solunum bak su buharı bu bir solunum
tepkimesidir adı üstünde Dehidrasyon
değildir sırf su çıktı diye Dehidrasyon
su atılma tepkimesidir demeyeceksin ya
da karbondioksitle H2O birleştirir bir
canlı besin üretir Bu nedir mesela
fotosentezdeki su girdi diye bunun adı
hidroliz olmaz hidroliz şudur büyük bir
molekülü su ile parçala onu küçük
molekül haline getir yani onu oluşturan
yapı haline getir Dehidrasyon da küçük
molekülleri birleştir daha büyük bir
madde oluştur burada bağ sayısı kadar su
açığa çıkar Yani şöyle söyleyeyim size
diyelim ki n tane monomeri yan yana
getiriyorsunuz buradan bir polimer elde
ediyorsunuz ve açığa su çıkıyor kaç tane
su çıkar
dediklerinde bağ kadar su çıkar
diyeceksiniz n -1 diye bir ezber
yapmayın bağ kadar su çıkar şimdi bakın
5 tane parmağım var doğru mu 1 2 3 4 4
tane boşluğum var kaç su çıkar 4 tane
neden n-1'e alışmayın diyorum biliyor
musunuz Çünkü ben size ileride diyeceğim
ki 1000 tane glikozla maltoz ürettiğiniz
de kaç su çıkar mesela bunun yeri
gelecek ama en azından buradan size
hazırlayayım maltoz işte glikozla
glikozun yan yana gelerek oluşturduğu
bileşik bir disakkarit birazdan
bahsedeceğim Şimdi iki tane Glukoz bir
tane maltoz oluştururken bir su çıkıyor
Neden bir tane su çıktı hocam şimdi n -1
Tamam güzel ama bak bağ kadar su çıktı
doğru mu şimdi ben dedim ki sana 1000
tane Glukoz kullanarak maltoz
sentezlediği kaç su çıkar sen diyeceksin
ki 2i tane glikozla Bir maltoz Elde
ettiğime göre 1000 tane glikozla 500
tane maltoz elde edebilirim ve bir
maltoza bir su çıkıyorsa 500 maltoza 500
su çıkar nerede n -1 sakın n -1 diye
kodlamayı tamam mı Yani bağ kadar su
çıkar derseniz bu tarz soruları hatalı
yapma ihtimaliniz ortadan kalkar
arkadaşlar Tamam alıştıracağım sizi
Merak etmeyin Peki bu hidroliz ya da
dehidrasyon su nereden geliyor yani su
nasıl açığa çıkıyor ya da su hidrolizde
nereye gidiyor Şimdi arkadaşlar suyu ben
biliyorum ki bir hidroksil bir de
hidrojen grubu var içinde ikisini
birleştirdiğimizde bakın h2a oluyor
şimdi burada şöyle bir mantık var
oluşurken kimden ne eksildi isse yani
Mesela iki tane Glukoz yan yana geliyor
maltoz oluşturuyor ya buradan su çıkıyor
Bir Glukoz hidroksil veriyor diğer
Glukoz hidrojen veriyor Bağları o
şekilde oluşturabiliyor Dolayısıyla
geriye doğru düşündüğümüzde Siz bir
suyun hidroksil hidroksil verene bir
suyun hidrojeni hidrojen verene
verdiğinizde O bağ ortadan kalkıyor
panik yapmayın Arkadaşlar bir şeyin
gidişatına sizi hazırlıyorum birkaç defa
duyun bu konu bittiğinde Bunlar
diyeceksiniz ki A çok çerezmm Tamam
rahat olun Şimdilik peki burada ne
anlatmış bakın bize işte ATP enerji
harcanacak iki tane monomer gelecek
birinin hidroksili var birinin hidrojeni
var Onlar açığa su çıkaracak ve şurada
bir bağ oluşacak hidrolizde ne oluyormuş
su şu bağı kırmak için hidroksil ve
hidrojen olarak ayrılıyor Kimin ne
eksiği varsa ona o bileşiği veriyor ve
aradan o bağ kopuyor ileride hocam
ileride hepsi oturacak rahat ol şimdi
karbonhidratlarla başlıyoruz karbon
hidrojen oksijen elementlerinden
oluşuyor bazılarında azot var Kimde var
Hemen şuraya yaz kitinde var
Tamam senin bilmen gereken zaten belli
başlı Karbonhidratlar olacak Ben mesela
sana diyeceğim ki azot içeren
polisakkarit için aşağıdakilerden
hangisi doğrudur sellz kitin glikojen
nişasta bu dördünü müfredatta size
öğretiyoruz bunların içerisinde kitinin
yapısında ki ameliyat ipliği yapımında
kullanıyoruz Biz kitini kitin azot
içeren polisakkarit olacak karbohidrat
lın Yapı taşına monosakkarit denir
sakkarit sakkaroz şeker demek Mono
sakkaritler Bunlar kim olabilir hocam
Hemen şöyle bir bakalım ne öğretiyoruz
biliyor musunuz size 5 karbonlular ve
altı karbonları monosakkarit dediğim
zaman 5 karbonlar ve 6ı karbonlular Peki
5 karbonların adı ne hocam Penta
latincede 5 olduğu için pentoz hegza da
6 olduğu için hego 5 karbonlar 6
karbonlular size öğrettiğimiz
monosakkaritler pentozlar yani 5
karbonlular
riboz Ve
deoksi riboz benim gibi yazın riboz ve
deoksiriboz riboz kimin yapısına
katılacak RNA'nın
ve en önemli enerji bile işiğim olan
ATP'nin
deoksiriboz da DNA'nın yapısına
katılacak bakın
deoksiriboz Türkçesi şu bir oksijeni
eksik riboz yani riboz mu büyük
deoksiriboz mu dediğimde riboz daha
büyük diyeceksiniz deoksiriboz bir
oksijeni eksik şimdi bakın buraya demiş
ki monosakkaritler genel olarak
ch2o kapa parantez n formülüyle Yani
cnh2n on kapalı formülüyle
formüller Aslında kaç karbon varsa
mesela 5 karbonlu mu C5 h10 o5 ama Bakın
ben buraya bir şey yazmışım kim Bozar
kim bu formüle uymaz demişim Siz
diyeceksiniz ki işte hoc
kim uymaz DNA'nın yapısına katılan
deoksiriboz uymaz Çünkü bunda bir
oksijen eksik diyeceksiniz 5 karbonlu C5
10 hidrojen ama o5 değil o4 riboz ise C5
h10 o 5'tir demek ki hangisi formüle
uymuyor muu
deoksiriboz zaten adı üstüne bir
oksijeni eksik riboz demek bu
monosakkaritler yani 5 karbonlar ve altı
karbonlar üretici canlılar tarafından
üretilebilir Mesela bir bitki
fotosentezle glikozu galaktoz fruktozu
üretebilir sonra biz bunları besinlerle
dışarıdan alırız biz bir Glukoz sentezi
galaktoz sentezi Fruktoz sentezini
sıfırdan yapamayız ama ne yaparız Mesela
diyelim ki hocam ben işte ekmek yedim
içinde nişasta var sindirdim Glukoz
Glukoz ihtiyacım varsa başka bileşiklere
karaciğerimi de çevirebilirim
karaciğerim diyor ki ben senin
ihtiyacını karşılarım Hatta adı fruktoza
benzeyen bir gazoz var ismini vermeyeyim
şimdi Reklam gibi olmasın onun içinde
Mesela işte bol miktarda Fruktoz var
çünkü Fruktoz çok şeker tadı verdiren
bir monosakkarit Dolayısıyla Arkadaşlar
biz bunu Eğer bir gıdanın içine koyarsak
insanlara bu gıda tatlı geleceği için
hoşlarına gider Fakat ben size bir şey
söyleyeyim eğer bir şeyin içinde Fruktoz
varsa Ve siz bunu alırsanız kolesterol
hastası olursunuz Arkadaşlar onu da
biyokimyaya aktaralım yani bir insan yağ
yiyerek kolesterol hastası olmuyor şeker
yiyerek kolesterol Hast oluyor ve bize
hasta yapan
fruktozdan
bisküvilerin böyle gazlı içeceklerin
neresi hepsinde Maalesef bu madde var
şimdi başa alalım pentozlar Penta 5
demek 5 karbon bizim öğreneceğimiz
özellikle iki tanesinin adı neydi riboz
deoksiriboz riboz kimin yapısına
katılıyordu RNA'nın deoksiriboz kimin
yapısına Katılıyor DNA'nın
deoksiriboz bir oksijeni eksik riboz duu
Kim cnh2n o for formülüne uymuyordu
deoksiriboz güzel şimdi geldim heksozlar
bakın burada hezo zlar Yani 6
karbonlular var ü şeyi bileceksin Glukoz
galaktoz Fruktoz Glukoz galaktoz Fruktoz
C6 h12 o6 C6 h12 o6 hepsinin kapalı
formülleri aynı açık formülleri farklı
böyle bileşiklere ne denir yapısal
izomer denir kapalı formülleri aynı açık
formülleri farklı yapısal izomer C6 h12
o6 Biz Glukoz fruktoz ve galaktoz
kullanıyoruz şimdi Ben size söyleyeyim
ben glikoz demiyorum arkadaşlar glikoz
diyorum Çünkü biyokimya ve Tıbbi
biyoloji
derslerinde glikoz Bütün şekerleri
temsil eder Glukoz ise 6 karbonlu şekeri
temsil eder bunlar yavaş yavaş bizde de
bizim kitaplarımızda da değişmeye
başladı Eskiden karbonhidrat deniyordu
ve biz diyorduk ki karbonhidrat değil
carbohydrate kelimesinden geliyor
yabancı kökenli O yüzden Şuradaki n
harfini kaldırın ve kaldırıldı
karbohidrat Glukoz ve glikoz arasındaki
fark neymiş glikoz Aslında Bütün
şekerleri temsil eden latince kökenli
bir kelime Glukoz ise 6 karbonlu Hani
Hocam niye Glukoz diyorsunuz falan şey
olmasın görüyor musunuz hangisi
deoksiriboz desem Siz diyeceksiniz ki
deoksi bir oksijeni eksik riboz demek
Bak bunda bir oksijen eksik Bu da niye
biliyor musunuz arkadaşlar üst düzey bir
sınav sorusudur
ve Öğretmeniniz bunu sorabilir Mesela
bir sözlü notu verme tadında ya da
bakalım hangi öğrencim güzel araştırma
yapmış tadında Ben olsam kesin sorarım
Bu arkadaşlar bir bileşiği daha kararlı
hale getirir bizim
dna'mızdaki
vermeye yatkın bir bileşik var aslında
bu birazcık kimya Barış hocanız biraz
böyle biyokimya eğitimi biraz değil
aslında hayatım biyokimya ile geçti de
bir de bir dönem Amerika'da organik
kimya bursu kazanmıştım ama gitmedim bu
da Aramızda Kalsın Eee Kimyayı o kadar
sevmiyorum şimdi burada bir yerde Eğer
şöyle bir yapı görüyorsanız Bunun yerine
bu kararlı olmuş artık orada tepkime
vermeyecek bir madde koymuşum çünkü dnam
yani stabil olmalı her önüne gelenle
tepkime vermemeli tamam mı Bu yüzden
böyle bir yapıya sahip dna'mızdaki
her birinin kendine özgü özellikleri var
az önce Dedim ki şu fruktozdan bir
başlayayım ne kadar tehlikeli ne kadar
çirkin bir şeker bu balda meyvelerde
bulunabilir Doğrudur ve bir meyveyi
arkadaşlar öyle suyunu sıktım içtim
yapmayın arkadaşlar meyveyi olduğu gibi
yiyin Çünkü bir portakal suyunun sizin
kan şekerinizi yükseltme hızı portakal
yediğinizde aynı değildir Tamam o yüzden
insülinin ii fırlatmayı İnsülin direnci
yaratmayacak sınız Çok şekerli
yemeyeceksiniz fıstık gibi sağlıklı bir
vücudunuz olacak yediğinize içtiğinizi
dikkat edin bazen bize dayatılan işte bu
çok sağlıklı portakal suyu Taze sıkılmış
için Tamam da şekeri yükseltiyor
meyveler o kadar masum değil arkadaşlar
ve meyve salatası mantığından uzak durun
çok mu seviyorsunuz her gün bir
tanesinden yiyin tamam çünkü bunlar da
Arkadaşlar çok fazla şeker ihtiva ediyor
ve bakın dikkat edin gıda Endüstrisi
tarafından tercih edilen bir
monosakkarit Neden Çünkü çok tatlı
insanların hoşuna gidiyor ve arkadaşlar
maalesef bak karaciğer yağlanması
obezite diyabet hocam şekerin yağlanmaya
Ne alakası var biyokimyada çok enteresan
bir tepkime var glikoliz tepkimesi
glukozu parçalayıp işte alt maddelere
ayırdığımız ve enerji ürettiğimiz bir
tepkime orada bir ara ürün var Eğer
Fruktoz girerse arkadaşlar oraya kontrol
edemiyoruz ve o tepkimenin yönü yağ
sentezine yani kolesterol sentezine
doğru gidiyor o yüzden bir insan kötü
kolesterol hastası şeker yediğinde
oluyor arkadaşlar yağ yediğinde değil
tamam mı zeytinyağı yiyerek kolesterol
hastası olmazsınız Yani bu çok düşük bir
ihtimal şeker yediğinizde olursunuz peki
galaktoz süt şekeridir sakın sadece
hayvanlarda bulunur demeyin Az önce ne
dedim bunların üçü de bakın bunların üçü
de bitkilerde olur Bitki bunları üretir
arkadaşlar ama neden hocam Süt şekeri
diyoruz Çünkü annelerimizin bizi
beslediği o laktoz var ya galaktoz danan
ve glukozun birleşmesiyle oluşuyor O
yüzden sütü üreten şeker manasına gel
geldiği için Süt şekeri diyorlar Glukoz
bizim kan şekerimiz yani insanların işte
parmak ucundan kanını alıyoruz ya da
işte biyokimya tüplerine kanını alıyoruz
Ve laboratuvara gönderiyoruz ya İşte
orada baktığımız şeker arkadaşlar
glikozdan topluma değişiyor Ama belli
bir miligram böl dilit üstüne çıktığında
Diyoruz ki ha bak sen şeker hastasısın
diyabet hastasısın ona göre dikkat et ya
beslenmeni düzelt ya işte biraz daha
Hareketli bir hayata geç Tabii Tip 1 Tip
2 bir sürü alt tipi var genetik olan var
doğuştan gelen var yaşam içerisinde
maalesef dönüştüğüm mesela Tip 2 Tip 2
biraz daha böyle yaşamsal dır arkadaşlar
işte
hareketsiz belinizin kalınlaştığı stres
yaptınız düzensiz beslediğiniz hocam
Türkiye'de sınava hazırlanan öğrencilere
anlatıyorsunuz Aynen öyle maalesef
arkadaşlar o yüzden Kendinize dikkat
edin ne nasıl depolanır vesaire bunları
Göreceğiz ama bitkiler nişasta depolar
bakteriler arkeler mantarlar hayvanlar
glikojen şeklinde depolar selüloz
bitkilerin duvarını oluşturur kitin
eklem bacakların dış iskeletinde
mantarların hücre duvarında olur bunlar
da polisakkarit türevleri birazdan
göreceğiz Şimdi bunlar neydi hocam
bunlar 6 karbonlu monosakkarit
monosakkariti ne yaptık 5 ve 6 diye
ayırdık 5'e pentozlar dedik riboz
deoksiriboz dedik 6 karbonlar Glukoz
galaktoz Fruktoz dedik Bunlar C6 h12 o6
kapalı formülleri aynı açık formülleri
farklı yapısal izomer dedik Glukoz kan
şekeridir Fruktoz meyve şekeridir
galaktoz süt şekeridir dedik ve ne dedik
Bunlar C6 h12 o6 bitkiler tarafından
üretilir hayvanlar bunları sıfırdan
üretemez dışarıdan alıp birbirlerine
dönüştürebilir Peki bu monosakkaritlerin
bir araya gelerek oluşturduğu yapılar
neydi disakkarit ya da polisakkarit di2
demek bakın Mono 1 D2 Poli çok
monosakkaritin yapısında karbon hidrojen
oksijen Aras Aki Bağlar Var ama iki
monosakkarit yan yana gelince adı
disakkarit olur peki disakkarit dediğim
şey nedir hocam bunlar burada da üç şey
Bileceksiniz maltoz sükroz Neredesin
laktoz He o da diğer sayfaya gitmiş
laktoz şimdi malt şekeri arpa şekeri bu
biraların vesairenin yapısına katılan
mal tozdur arkadaşlar ve iki tane
glukozun birleşmesiyle meydana gelir
Glukoz ı glikoz maltoz ı su kaç tane bağ
var o kadar su oluştu sükroz glikozla
fruktozun birleşmesiyle oluşur hop bir
tane su oluştu laktoz ise glikozla
galaktozun birleşmesiyle oluşur Glukoz
artı Glukoz maltoz Glukoz artı Fruktoz
sükroz Glukoz artı galaktoz laktoz
galaktoz Süt şekeri laktoz da Süt şekeri
bakın birbirine bağlayalım genel kültür
Hani laktozsuz süt Niye Çünkü bazı
insanlar süt içtiğinde Karnı ağrıyor hep
hepsinin içerisinde en az bir tane
Glukoz var gördünüz mü ezberimizi
kolaylaştıracağı hepsinin içinde bir
tane en az Glukoz var sütle alakalı olan
galaktoz şimdi sükroz çay şekeri
glikozla glukozu da birleştirdim maltozu
arpa şekerini malt şekerini Malt içeceği
ne yaptık biz monosakkaritleri bir araya
getirdik Glikoz glikoz maltoz Glukoz
galaktoz laktoz Glukoz früktoz sükroz
dedik laktoz Süt şekeri oldu çay şekeri
oldu maltoz malt arpa şekeri oldu şimdi
bunların her birinin içindeki şu bağ
pardon şu bağ glikozidik bağ ya da
glikozit bağı denir arkadaşlar bakın
glikozit bağı Demek ki
monosakkaritlerin bir araya glikozit
bağıyla gelip
disakkaritleri oluşturduğu Bu yapılar bu
üç yapıyı göreceğiz bitti Bu kadar
bunlar
disakkarit geldim polisakkarit ama bir
mola veriyor yorum önce şunları bir
toparlayalım polimer monomer Poli çok
birbirine benzer monomerlerin yan yana
gelerek oluşturduğu bileşiktir ama
bunların yüzlercesi O yüzden lipitler
polimer değildir Bu cebimde Dehidrasyon
hidroliz hidroliz su ile parçalamak
büyük bir molekülü onu oluşturan
yapılara dönüştürmek
Dehidrasyon küçük molekülleri yan yana
getirip büyük molekül oluşturmak ve bağ
kadar su açığa çıkartmaktır Bu da tamam
karbonhidratlar monosakkaritler
disakkaritler polisakkaritler olmak
üzere üçe ayrıldı monosakkaritleri de 5
karbon 6 karbon olarak ayırdık 5
karbonlar pentoz altı karbonlar hezo
oldu pentozlar riboz deoksiriboz hego
zlar Glukoz galaktoz Fruktoz oldu Sonra
bu monosakkaritlerden 6 karbonlu
olanları kendi aralarında bir araya
getirdik Glukoz artı Glukoz maltoz
Glukoz artı Fruktoz sükroz Glukoz Art
galaktoz laktoz dedik ve her biri
glikoziti bağlarla bir araya geldiği
için bağ kadar da su açığı çıkarttık bu
kadar şimdi polisakkaritlere girmiyorum
burada bir mola veriyorum 2 videoda
polisakkaritler ve yine konu özeti